ていた
[音楽]
先ほどぱ東金のですね非常にあの素晴らしい曲を聴かせていただいて本当にあのこれは
納言感じだったんですけれども
私の今日の話は
この統率ということは聞いた事はございますか
あまり聞いたことはないと思うんですけれどもですね今日はの
これについて少しだけですね話をしたいと思います
正しいあのあまり硬い話ではですね
なかなか歯モーションはありませんので
皆さん今日少し実行できるかなというような話をですね
少し入れて話をさせていただきたいと思います私の年齢は現在71歳です
だから皆さんのお父さんお母さんの年齢を考えてみるとわかると思うんですけれども
ですね
おそらくこの中で私が最年長だと思いますでそういう
年寄りの話だと送っていいですねちょっと聞いていただきたいなと思っています
あのこの a ですけれども
2011年の3月11日にですね
東日本大震災が起こりました
そして
10位タイですね約10万人
現地につぎ込んでですねそして
生成と
行動をしてそして任務を完遂してまいりました
いったいそれは何がそうさせるので評価とこういう話なんですけどね
要するあの
here けど more here それはティ
そうするということにちょっと変わってくるかなというふうに思っていますので
まあその役の話ですね少しだけしたいと思います
統率というのはですねちょっと真面目な話ですけれども
一起用するということです
式ですねこれは法令とか権限に基づいて指揮下の部隊とかあるいはそういう会社でいう
と部下の人がちん子ですね
実行を命ずるもの
式です明治のことですだから強制的なものです
投票というのは
心の問題いきますかね
要するに分の人格とかそういうのを磨いてその間かで打って従わせていくという投票と
いう問題があります
もう一つは管理ですね管理というのはヒトモノカネ情報
そういうのを集めてですねそれを任務に向かって邁進す
させるとこういう機能があります今日はですね何を話しをしたいかといいますと
式というのは権限に基づいて強制力でやるものですからそれはちょっと置いておきまし
て
投与という
人間の心と心のふれあいを教育してるとかですね
あるいは人格による肝火を及ぼすものとかあるいは
良きフォロワーシップこれに基づいて式をしていくという
投票ということについてですねちょっとお話をしたいなと思っています
この投票というものはひろりあの大学フォロワーしで
人間関係なんですね部下がその人のために命を落としてでも頑張りたいという気持ちに
させる
これは人間関係つまりコミュニケーション能力というものだと思います
まあいろいろ考えてもらえばわかりますが皆さんが例えば夫婦関係とか結構されている
方は少ないかもしれませんけれども
あるいは親子関係あるいは兄弟との関係
あるいは親戚とかですねまわりとの紙系学校の投薬との関係
あるいは会社に入ってる人は会社の同僚とかですね上司部下との関係とこういう年月に
向けというのがたず起こりますその中でうまくやっていくためにはどうすればいいのか
と
これはですね実はある会社
間に勤めておりまして
もうほとんど辞める人のですね90%が人間関係で辞める辞めちゃう
あとお仕事が技術体のことにできないとかですねそういうことで辞める人は2%くらい
しかいないんですけれども
実は人間関係このこれでやめる人が90%言うとじゃあその人間関係
コミュニケーション能力でも磨くためにはどうすればいいのかというの話をですね
進めていきたいなと思うんですね
これは何ですか皆さん
これを見てですね
これはですね
皆さんを笑ってますねに国をしますよね
笑顔です
コミュニケーション能力のですねスタートは映画王ということですよね
これは万国共通でですねええ
もう笑顔を作れば必ず相手笑顔で返してくれます
そうですよね映像というのが私は大事だと思っているんですね
コミュニケーションの力を作る一番最初は笑顔
笑顔これをですね是非作ってもらいたいと思うんですね
この笑顔があれば心が2いるということなんですけれどもある言葉があるんですけれど
も笑顔を作るのに1ドルもいらない
そうですよね
ところがこの笑顔の効果という価値というものは100万ロルに値すると
言われておりますっていうことは笑顔つかないと損ですよね
この笑顔を作るというのはやはり自分の心の状態というのはよくないと映画を作れませ
ん
もし頃状態が悪くて腹が勝ってるとか起こっているとするならばですね
形だけでもいいから映画をつくってほしいとまず形から入る
これは非常に重要だと思いますのでまずコミュニケーション能力の第一は笑顔だ
こういうふうに思っております
これは何ですか
皆さん考えてみてください
あのこれはですねあの
2番目にコミュニケーション能率で大事なことということで私が勝手に決めていること
なんですけれどもですね
勝手に私は2番目に大事なものと決めてるんですけれどもそれは
行くことですけっこと
人の話を聞くことでもけぐといってももし相手が話をしてくれなかったらどうしますか
消えませんよね
聞きたいんだけどもけないとするとかどうしますか
質問をする
4坪
例えば笑顔をつくって初めて会いました
あなたはどこから来たの質問をしましたよね
そしたらたとえばエジプトレストなんですね
エジプト egypt どんなとこですかね
砂漠がありますとかねまあいろいろあるじゃないですか
どんどんそういうふうに質問をしていくん
そうすると相手が話をしてくれますから
結構度ができます
人間はですね
話をすることによって満足する動物なんです
そうですね
おいかいますね人間は話をすることによって満足する動物です
どんどん話をさせるとこの人いい人がまだ花しようってなっていくんですね
ところが一方的に自分だけしゃべったらどうなりますか
もう話行きたくないともうなっちゃいますよね
だからこの聞くことっていうのが2番目に大事な角ということで聴くためには質問を
するということですね
質問をしてどんどん相手に話をさせるということですね
だいたいですね人というのはしゃべりで差がありますから
だいたい50%孤児フィフティーフィフティーで話をしていると思ったときに
だいたい自分が80%はしゃべっています
ということを相手の話をしっかり聞こうと思ってですね
聞くじゃないですかでも今日は80%キーだなあと思った時に
だいたい皮膚 p フィフティでしょ入ってると客観リブよそんなものなんですねだ
から大いにですね
質問をして喋らせるそうすると相手は満足をするそうすると
をその人を好きになるということです
喋らせる人を好きになるこれが
人間の一つのですね特徴ですので
これもコミュニケーション能力の第二番目に必要なかなというふうに思っております
三番目は何でしょうか
あすごいその通りですねえっ
これはですね褒めるということですね
褒める
これ褒めると嬉しいですよね
だコミュニケーション能力で大事なことの3番目は褒めるということなんです
でも
褒めればいいということでしょうかそうしたらですねなんでもいいから褒めればいいん
だということではなかなかですね
また褒めてるみたいになっちゃっていいですね相手も嫌になるほどもあってありますの
で褒めるということは
ほめ方が一つあるんだということですね
それはちょっとようなしますと
そうですね例えば
このに来たいいですねーどねやってますねえとアリー
込められたしますそれはもちろんれ仕事かもしれませんけれども
褒めた後に質問を吸っ
これは誰が選んだんですか
どこで買ったんですか
ねっ
その所を見せなかったんですかよしじゃあ今度私5
という風に褒めた後に質問をする
これが冬型のまあ一つの方法なんですけどね
もう一つあります
ほめ方で言いますとねボイスチェンジというのがありまして
8数字年例えばどんな
例がいいですかね皆さんが
友達と友達がいるとします
私が
例えばモハメド組んでもいいんですけれども安倍くんと話をしているときに誰かのこと
を褒めたとします
そうしますと私はその人に御天風があなたのことを褒めてたよ
こう言います
そうするとその人はどうなりますか
その方
モバメの子も好きになるん
同時に
スタへた私の空き無
ということは私は伝えることに徹すればいいということですね
あなたのことを見てたよねそういうふうにボイスチェンジをするそうするとその方は
褒めた人を好きになりますけども
そのさえた人も好きになる
でこれをですねどんどん循環させていけば非常にいいわけですね
例えばまあもうちょっとからね行きましょうかね
例えば
自分のまあ子供さんでもいいんですけれども
隣の人がお宅の
息子さんは素晴らしいですねどいつも挨拶をしてくれるとこう言ったでしょとないう人
もい
そうするとおかあさんはそれを聞いて夜ご飯の時にですね
実は隣のおばあちゃんがあなたのことを上だよとそして挨拶を剛三できると素晴らしい
こうして褒めたとしますでそうするとその子供さんはどうなりますか
隣のおばあちゃんを好きになります
そしてこれからもどんどん挨拶をするようになります
と同時に
伝えたお母さんも好きになる
いうことですね
これはですね押印使ってもらいたいなと思うんですけれども
まあ今言いましたようにこの
褒めるということですねこれは3つ目の私の
人間関係コミュニケーションの能力のですね重要なところだと思っております
でこれを1ね大江使ってもらいたいなとこういうふうに思います
そのようなことでですね
今日私がお話したのは
東捕卒という人を率いる
例えば野球のですね日本シリーズありましたよね
あの宮藤監督がですねえーすごい采配をしたと思ったんですね
そしてその月その
ダイエーホークスのですねオーナーディアの桜備わる
会長がですねー
不動監督の統率は素晴らしかったん
個入ってましたいや統率は何たって言った宿要したんですね
良い選手でも帰るときにはカエル
いいピッチングをしてるんだけども佐藤読んでスパッと代えれるとかですね
あるいは4番なんか売ってた人にですねバントさせたりとかですね
それを平気でやるんですね匹をしたんですねところがみんなの心が通じ言ってるんです
から
非常にですねこれが続いて投票ができてたということなんですね
そして統率ができてたということで素晴らしいあの
結果を残したとこれ思いますこれはお互いの信頼関係ができているということですね
だから何人かを引きですね皆さんも何かやることが多いと思うんですけれどもそれを時
にはまず式雄実行を命ずることと目的を達成するために厳しい
命令これを実行させることとまた人間関係をしっかりと作っておくこと
これが非常に大事だと思います
最後にですねもう一点だけを話して終わりたいと思います
例えば10人に立ってしますここに10人人がいたらですね
住人の意見は全て正しいです
10人いたら10人とも全部正しい
意見をなばいい
もしこれが間違っているとすれば
収集日やいけないですよね間違ってみて一生懸命修繕稲毛
ところが
そこには間違いがあるわけではないんです
住林いて10人がただそこに違うだけなんですね
違いがあるだけで間違いではない
ということですね
だから何かあった時にうそうだねその通り
も違ってないんですから
でも間違っていると思ったらいや違うと言わなきゃいけないじゃないですか
ところが10人いれば10人とも間違いは間違いはない
ただそこには違いがあって間違いがあるわけではないんだというふうに思っています
まあそういう話でですね
終わりますけれども人間関係ですねこれは人生の幸福と成功を決める
微ほぼを止める驚異的なものです
だからどんなに頭が良くてもどんなに能力が高くてもですね
この人間関係の調整のる人間関係の技術これを焼かないと人生は成功しない
幸福になれないとこういうふうに思っております私は以上ですありがとうありました
[拍手]